ma question en fait étant donné que
le pib est directement liée à la
consommation d'énergie on va avoir une
chute du pib en tout cas on peut le
souhaiter mais il se trouve qu'une chute
du pib dans la structure actuelle de
notre économie
ça amènerait directement à des
destructions d'emplois nous comment
faire pour que la descente énergétique
soit socialement acceptable eh bien il
faut vous avez la réponse
faux dit bio hors fo a organisé la
diminution du pouvoir d'achat et cette
organisation n'est acceptable qu'à
partir du moment où en face vous arriver
aussi à faire baisser les charges alors
la première charge aujourd'hui c'est
celle du logement on va retomber sur ce
que je disais tout à l'heure
comme de toute façon pour des raisons
énergétiques il faut faire dégonfler les
grandes villes ça tombe bien
si je vous enlève 30% à votre salaire
mais vous allez dans un endroit où se
loger coûte 30% moins cher que par
ailleurs vous fait pousser une partie de
votre bouffe
bon bah vous achèterez moins de fringues
et point de smartphones plus pas si
c'est très grave ce dont je suis
intimement persuadé c'est que la seule
le le seul contexte dans lequel ce genre
de choses est négociable c'est si en
face je vous amène de l'espoir dit
autrement je vous dégage le brouillard
devant en vous disant quand même tu as
devant là ça monte un peu on va
transpirer un peu mais je dégage
l'horizon et on est sûr qu'on va pas
tomber dans une crevasse
je pense qu'il faut absolument tenir ce
genre de discours mais on en revient à
ce que je veux dire juste avant il faut
être capable de faire la pédagogie du
problème si on veut être capable de
vendre les forts face au problème
ce que je crois aujourd'hui c'est que
dans la population française
une partie des gens ont confusément
compris ils n'ont pas explicitement
compris il continue à tout confond ils
ont quand même confusément compris qu'il
y avait que demain ça allait pas être la
répétition d'hyères et qu' il y allait y
avoir des trucs bizarres
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui quelque
part on n'est pas très loin de pouvoir
commencer à accompagner ce mouvement
déjà en expliquant moi moi je sais que
je me suis jamais fait sortir d'un
endroit où j'expliquais les choses y
compris à des syndicalistes cgt
quand on explique les choses et qu'on
explique pourquoi effectivement il ya
des difficultés devant nous qui sont pas
liées à la mauvaise volonté tel ou tel
mais qui sont juste liée à la façon dont
le système s'est construit en général
les gens sont d'accord enfin on va
discuter
il commence à avoir envie de regarder
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et c'est
alors un truc qui revient
systématiquement c'est clair que
c'est dans une privation général le mode
de vie de bernard arnault est encore
plus intolérable et ça c'est vrai et
c'est un vrai problème
alors il ya plusieurs manières de faire
baisser la richesse de bernard arnault
et la plaint on peut nationaliser sa
boîte on va brûler non mais pas de
manière je pense qu'alors je rebondis
sur ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur
les économistes qui réfléchissent pas
dans le bon contexte jeu il faut
probablement réfléchir des trucs comme
ça de même que tous les gens qui ont des
pavillons de banlieue qui vaudront plus
rien dans un monde à l'énergie
contrainte parce que c'est quoi une
banlieue c'est la zone où vous allez
mettre des gens qui sont indispensables
à une activité de type urbain c'est pas
des agriculteurs que vous mettez dans
des pavillons de banlieue c'est les
employés de bureau donc vous mettez des
gens qui font partie du système
énergivores et qui le jour où le système
énergivores n'est plus là font partie
d'une agglomération qui n'a plus les
moyens de trouver sa subsistance à
l'extérieur et d'une agglomération qui
est quand même prudents une banlieue
pour trouver sa subsistance en elle-même
parce que c'est pas avec un jardin
ouvrier de 50 mètres carrés que vous
allez faire bouffer toute la famille
toute l'année non donc le pavillon de
banlieue dans un monde en contraction
énergétique ma théorie c'est qu'un jour
il vaudra plus rien peut-être qu'il
faudrait anticiper le truc en créant un
fonds d'indemnisation pour propriétaires
de pavillons de banlieue
non mais il ya tout à inventer dans ce
monde là puisque c'est un monde qu'on a
jamais connu c'est une nouvelle
planification qui nous faut bien sûr
qu'il va planification alors acquis et
non mais c'est quoi l'horizon de temps
qui 50 à 100 ans
bien sûr qu'il nous faut une
planification alors là je redis un truc
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure les français
sont les champions du monde de
l'optimisation sous contrainte
ils sont aussi c'est aussi le seul pays
communistes d'europe de l'ouest la
france est le seul pays communistes
d'europe de l'ouest
on est un pays foncièrement égalitaire
foncièrement égalitaire je veux dire les
gens ça débecte mon voisin que je gagne
10% de plus que lui
enfin on est un pays foncièrement
égalitaire alors ça peut avoir des côtés
horripilant mais ça aussi un énorme
avantage face à la contrainte que je
viens de décrire
parce que justement on est un pays
accessible à l'idée de collectif
on est un pays dans lequel la part des
prélèvements obligatoires est très élevé
pour autant conscient pour plus vers le
soit dit en passant
moi j'ai fait des petits calculs quand
la dépense de santé et de retraite parce
que c'est essentiellement ça qui échappe
aux prélèvements obligatoires dans les
autres pays passent directement dans le
privé
les gens sont pas nécessairement en
meilleure santé et ils n'ont pas
nécessairement une retraite plus sympa
donc l'idée est qu'avec moins de
prélèvements obligatoires en supporte
moins en sorte de mieux cdu c'est de la
foutaise de gens comparent réfléchit
plus loin que le bout de leur nez le met
donc dans ce monde là on va avoir besoin
d'un effort collectif extrêmement
développé je le redis on a une chance en
france c'est qu'on n'est pas accessible
à ça beaucoup plus que les américains
qui sont perdus pour la cause pour
l'éternité
donc aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait
l'ambition d'imposer notre façon de voir
le monde aux américains et pas l'inversé
mais vraiment un jeu je suis sérieux
quand je dis ça j'ai mis vingt ans à me
faire à cette idée mais je le pense
j'ai vécu aux états unis quand j'étais
étudiant donc je viens de très loin mais
je le pense vraiment ce que ce que je
viens de dire
et il va donc falloir inventer une
planification
il va donc falloir inventer la façon de
dégonfler de système et on va avoir un
débat très douloureux sur la question
démographique
parce que alors là je vais peut-être
choquer quelques unes et quelques-uns
dans cette salle je pense que le débat
du moment sur la barre et surréaliste
parce que dans un monde peuplé de 8
milliards d'habitants se demander
comment je peux rajouter des êtres
humains sur terre me semble pas être la
première priorité
mais vraiment je pense qu'on se prépare
juste à faire des gens qui sont
malheureux donc aujourd'hui c'est
l'exact inverse ce qu'il faut faire et
je vais reprendre le propos d'un père
jésuite que j'adore capelle gaël giraud
voilà qui a une vidéo faut mesurer ce
que ça veut dire chez un jésuite ce
qu'il advient va chercher un cadeau
il ya une vidéo de lui qu'ils tournent
sur internet donc vous pourrez aller
vérifier dans lequel il dit l'aide au
développement en france et il était chef
économiste de l'agencé française de
développement quand il a dit ça on peut
vous dire que vraiment
eh bien gaël a dit les trois priorités
que devrait avoir l'aide au
développement aujourd'hui les 3 une
équipe priorité devrait être l'éducation
des femmes
le planning familial et les systèmes de
retraite c'est-à-dire tout ce qui permet
de contenir la démographie de façon j'ai
envie de dire raisonnablement tous corps
il faut se concentrer sur ses trois
trucs là et on oublie les ponts et les
routes et les aéroports et les machins
tout ça en fait une croix dessus alors
un peu de développement agricole dans la
mesure où c'est compatible avec une
démographie qui se calme voilà sinon le
problème et il est juste bon il se
trouve que mon information de première
main sur les soirées chez vous revient
tout juste d'un stage à madagascar de
terrain voilà compter les zébus le début
cette capitale du pays dont malgache
et bien c'est très simple ce qui se
passe d'avoir la population croit vous
n'êtes pas un homme si vous n'avez pas
défricher votre parcelle et donc les
gens vont couper la forêt qu'est ce que
voulait faire contre ça la seule chose
que vous pouvez faire c'est d'essayer de
changer le schéma dans lequel la
population croît indéfiniment il ya pas
qu autre chose à faire donc je sais mais
c'est un débat difficile de même qu'en
france on va avoir un débat sur les
allocations familiales etc
c'est des débats difficiles mais ils
faut les avoir parce qu'à mon avis ne
pas les avoir c'est pire c'est la
régulation involontaire du système et je
rappelle aux agro qui sont dans cet
amphi que les populations animales n'ont
que deux modes de régulation naturelle
c'est la famille de la maladie vous vous
rappelez famine et la maladie
alors la guerre c'est un accélérateur de
la famille et de la maladie c'est en
général ça qui fait des gros dégâts dans
une guerre c'est que les gens ont plus à
bouffer et qu'ils ont plus la
possibilité de se soigner les morts
directs dans le conflit je vous rappelle
que la première guerre mondiale a fait
moins de morts que la grippe espagnole
qui a suivi et dans les morts de la
seconde guerre mondiale vous avez
énormément de morts chez les civils qui
sont des gens qui sont morts de faim et
de maladie énormément énormément donc le
voilà donc les donc ne pas accepter de
regarder en face ce problème là c'est
signé pour le fait que la famine et la
maladie et les guerres à côté tension
règle le problème à notre place